(Dieser Film beginnt in der Schweiz.)
(Er handelt von Erwartungen
und Enttäuschungen.)
(Aber auch von Heimat.)
(Nur: Was ist Heimat?)
(Als ich eineinhalbjährig war,
ist meine Familie mit mir
aus dem Iran
in die Schweiz geflüchtet.)
(Nach Chur. Dort haben wir
ein neues Leben angefangen.)
(39 Jahre später weiss ich nicht,
ob ich Schweizer oder Iraner bin.
Oder beides?)
(Das ist meine Geschichte,
aber es könnte genauso gut
die Geschichte
Tausender anderer Menschen sein,
die in die Schweiz gekommen sind
und hier
ein besseres Leben gesucht haben.)
(Ich muss zurück in den Iran.)
(Es ist eine Reise zu meinen Wurzeln,
in meine Lebensgeschichte.)
(Es wird vielleicht schwierig,
und vielleicht tut es auch weh.)
* Eindringliche Streichmusik *
Kannst du mal die Kamera ausschalten?
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Familie ist ...
Die Familie ist sicher wichtig.
Die Familie.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Ich wurde sehr familiär erzogen,
in einem
sehr intakten Familienverhältnis.
Als der Vater gestorben ist,
bröckelte das etwas auseinander.
Darum hat sich der Stellenwert
der Familie für mich etwas ...
Der ist für mich nicht ganz so hoch.
Ich bin
zwischen zwei Kulturen aufgewachsen.
Man hat zu Hause die andere Seite,
das Persische, doch gespürt.
Aber ich habe diese Kultur etwas
vergessen. Aber sie ist auch in mir.
Sie wurde mir als Kind
auch beigebracht.
Kiano, komm her!
Aber ich habe sie zur Seite gelegt.
Das hat auch mit dem Tod meines
Vaters zu tun, als ich knapp 22 war.
Ich lebte es nicht mehr,
sprach die Sprache nicht mehr,
obwohl ich mit der Sprache, dem
Essen, den Gerüchen aufgewachsen bin.
Jetzt bin ich knapp 40,
das ist der Zeitpunkt, ich spüre das.
* Telefon-Freizeichen *
* Ein Mann spricht Farsi. *
Oh!
* Salar spricht Farsi. *
Wie sagt man?
Bye-bye.
Ah! Ich merke:
Mein Farsi ist so eingeschlafen.
Ich ringe wirklich nach Wörtern.
Ich muss schauen, dass ich
in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen
noch etwas Persisch rede.
Aber es ist alles auf Kurs.
Wir haben die Papiere fertig,
wir werden in Teheran Hilfe haben
und jemanden,
der uns die Stadt zeigen kann,
der im gleichen Alter ist.
Es fällt mir gerade
ein Stein vom Herzen.
Es kommt jetzt alles näher.
Es ist spannend,
eine Herausforderung.
Vielleicht kommen wir nie am Ziel an.
So platt es klingt:
Hier ist der Weg das Ziel.
Ich bin froh ... Ich möchte schon
über die Grenze kommen.
Ich muss in das Land.
Ich glaube an das Gute.
Ein Iraner würde sagen: Inshallah.
* Orientalisch anmutende Klänge *
* Kiano bellt. *
(Ich bin im April 1979 geboren.)
(Meine Mutter, Sibylle Bahrampoori,
eine Baslerin.)
(Sie hat die Handelsschule besucht.)
(Mein Vater, Iradj Bahrampoori,
hat in Basel studiert.)
(Geboren wurde er im Iran.)
(Mein Bruder Geev, rechts im Bild,
ist 18 Monate älter als ich.)
(1980
bricht der Erste Golfkrieg aus.)
(Unter Beschuss muss meine Familie
unser Haus in Teheran verlassen.)
(Wir fliehen in die Schweiz.)
(Ich bin in Chur aufgewachsen
und habe das KV gemacht.)
(Als mein Vater starb, war ich 22.)
Hoi.
- Hoi.
Hoi, ciao Salar.
Hoi! Geht es dir gut?
- Ja.
Hoi, hoi, hoi.
Schön bist du gekommen, Geev.
- Ciao.
Bist du gut gefahren?
Tipptopp.
- Okay.
Hoi, Salar!
- Hoi.
Da gibt es Khoresht-e Bademjan.
Dann habe ich noch
ein Gericht mit Huhn.
Ah, so!
- Ich muss den Reis noch wärmen.
Und Ghormeh Sabzi.
- Das ist eine Überraschung.
Das hatte ich seit Jahren
nicht mehr von dir. - Guten Appetit.
Wie sagt man auf Persisch
"guten Appetit"? - Nooshejaan.
Nooshejaan.
Bon appetit.
Als Kinder haben wir
fast nur persisch gegessen.
Oder? War das so?
- Ja, das war so.
Es fällt mir auch am leichtesten
zum Kochen.
Weil ich zuerst
persisch kochen gelernt habe.
Wie habt ihr zwei es so?
Wie ähnlich oder unterschiedlich
seid ihr?
Wir haben schon als Buben gestritten
an diesem Tisch.
Immer viel gestritten.
Wir haben uns aber auch sehr lieb.
... gehabt!
- Es geht nicht ohne ...
... und nicht mit.
* Lachen *
Nein, nein.
Salar ist einfach das Teufelchen.
Er hält sich nicht gern an Regeln,
geht seinen eigenen Weg,
muss jede Erfahrung selber machen.
Mhm.
Das zieht aber auch
sehr viel Gutes mit sich.
* Einzelne Klavierakkorde *
Wird es auch
eurem Familiengefüge etwas bringen,
euch mehr zusammenhalten,
wenn Salar zurückkommt?
Das werden wir sehen.
Das müssen wir offen lassen.
Sein Vater hat ihm ja vorgelebt, wie
er mit der Familie kommuniziert hat.
Das hat Salar aber total verdrängt.
Er ging seinen eigenen Weg.
Ganz anders als Geev?
Ganz anders als Geev.
Ja, wo immer.
Aber auch Salar
hat sicher viele positive Seiten.
Nebst den negativen.
Es täuscht eben. Ihr glaubt,
ich hätte diese Werte nicht.
Ich habe sie schon.
Aber die Werte,
die Vater uns mitgegeben hat,
und dass ich merke,
dass wir anders sind
als "normale, klassische" Schweizer -
das ist mir klar.
Und das ist ein Teil,
weshalb ich auf die Reise will.
Ciao, Salar, mach's gut! Tschüss!
- Tschüss. Pass auf dich auf!
Gleichfalls, pass auf dich auf!
Ciao.
(Auch in so schönen Momenten
spüre ich Vorwürfe.)
(Ich war nicht immer so,
wie ich hätte sein sollen.)
Kommt gut zurück!
- Pass auf dich auf, gell!
Pass auf dich auf!
Grüsse alle von uns.
Tschüss.
- Und eine gute Zeit.
Vielen Dank.
- Eine gute Zeit.
Alles wird gut.
Ciao.
- Vielen Dank.
Inshallah.
- Inshallah.
Hierher zu kommen
ist mittlerweile schön.
Es tut mir einfach für ihn leid,
weil er so lebensfroh war.
Ich weiss noch,
wie er das nicht verstehen konnte.
So habe ich es damals empfunden,
als er gehen musste.
Es war für ihn sehr schwierig,
uns so zurückzulassen.
Und selber so aus dem Leben gerissen
zu werden innert fünf Monaten.
Ihm war es wichtig, dass wir den Iran
kennen, von seinen schönen Seiten.
Er würde sich sicher freuen,
dass ich jetzt auf die Reise gehe.
* Melancholische Klänge *
(Bevor es losgeht,
zeige ich mich noch mal so,
wie man mich in der Schweiz kennt.)
("Glanz und Gloria" -
mein berufliches Zuhause.)
* Verspielte Klaviermusik *
Das ist mein letzter Arbeitstag, wir
haben unsere alljährlichen Glorys,
eine Verleihung, bei der die Promi-
nenten in verschiedenen Kategorien
nominiert sind
und ausgezeichnet werden.
Für mich ist jetzt noch Abschluss
vor der grossen Reise.
Zusammen sind wir stark.
Zusammen sind wir stark
und zusammen macht es Spass.
Ja, jetzt wird man nervös,
jetzt kommt es.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Jetzt geht es erst los, oder?
Ja, jetzt geht es los.
Schönen Abend miteinander.
* Titelmelodie von "Glanz & Gloria" *
Danke schön!
Ach!
Ah, ein gutes Gefühl.
Es ist gut gegangen.
Ja, wirklich.
- Es ist schön.
Ich bin froh. Oh, Salar!
Jetzt haust du ab?
Ja, jetzt haue ich ab.
- Du kommst wieder zurück!
Ja, ich komme wieder zurück.
Jetzt will ich gerade nicht gehen.
Ich habe natürlich
schon vieles vorbereitet,
aber der letzte Schliff
ist noch zu machen.
Wo gehen wir denn Ski fahren?
Das werden wir sehen.
Im Iran ist jetzt ...
Es ist Mitte Januar,
es hat dort sehr viel Schnee.
Es gibt verschiedene Skigebiete.
Es ist eines der grossen Ziele,
einer meiner Bubenträume:
Wenn wir schon im Januar dort sind,
dass wir sicher Ski fahren werden.
Es war abgemacht:
Zwei Gepäckstücke darf ich mitnehmen.
Ich habe mich daran gehalten.
Das werde ich vermissen.
(Dass wir das Auto -
früher als uns lieb ist -
wieder ausräumen müssen, ahnen wir
nicht, als wir in Zürich losfahren.)
So, ich würde sagen, in Zürich
setzen wir den Tageszähler auf null.
Wir starten. Ich habe Gieri mit-
genommen als Andenken an Graubünden.
Ich bin sonst nicht der Tiermensch
mit so künstlichem Zeug,
aber Gieri kommt mit auf die Reise.
Mal schauen.
Also, wir fahren los!
Vamos!
- Bist du bereit, Reto?
Ich glaube es nicht.
* Gefühlvolle Ballade:
"Heartbeats" von Jose Gonzalez *
(Von Zürich nach Teheran
sind es fast 5'000 km.)
(Eine Reise durch acht Länder.)
(Eine Reise
zu meinen iranischen Wurzeln.)
(Ein Roadtrip mit meinem Freund
und Filmemacher Reto Wettstein.)
(Ohne ihn könnte ich
dieses Abenteuer nicht wagen.)
# Mind is a razor blade.
Hey, wir sind gestartet.
Nein, ich meine es ernst. Ich ...
- Nein, ich bin ...
Ich bin auch noch nicht ganz ...
- Ich bin auch noch nicht ...
# One night of magic rush.
Ich kann noch nicht ganz glauben,
dass ich wirklich hier sitze,
auf der A13 Richtung Chur,
und eigentlich Richtung Iran fahre.
Das ist schon unglaublich.
# The colors red and blue.
Im Moment habe ich das Gefühl,
ich sei da in der Schweiz zu Hause.
Dieses Gefühl
werde ich wohl auch immer haben.
Es fragt sich nur,
wie stark ich mich
dort zu Hause fühle.
Das ist eine Frage,
die mich beschäftigt.
Mich beschäftigt auch die Frage,
wie stark man sich überhaupt
irgendwo zu Hause fühlen muss.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
(Wir treffen Pat, eine lebenslange
Freundin meiner Mama.)
Hallo, Pat.
- Hallo.
Mei, ist das nett!
Nach so vielen Jahren.
Ich glaube, seit Papa gestorben ist,
haben wir uns nicht mehr gesehen.
(Pat hat die Liebe meiner Eltern
von Anfang an miterlebt.)
Dann klingelt mein Telefon.
Aus England, die Oma, die Katie.
"Bitte, bitte, komm!
Ich brauche dich ganz dringend."
"Sibylle hat sich verliebt -
in einen Iraner."
"Und sie will den heiraten."
Ich glaube, sie war nicht mal 18.
Sie war 17.
Ich kam natürlich rüber.
Sie sagte:
"Du musst ihr das ausreden."
"Du musst ihr sagen,
sie kann den Iraner nicht heiraten."
Ich bin hingefahren
und habe gesehen:
Es ist alles umsonst.
Sie ist total verliebt.
Ich habe gewusst: Die heiraten.
Er war mit ihr sehr, sehr nett.
Ja.
- Dein Vater war ein Gentleman.
Er war kein englischer Gentleman,
aber ein iranischer Gentleman.
Ich wusste, es würde ihr gut gehen.
Was war ich für ein Kind?
- Oh Gott!
Du warst gerade das,
was eigentlich deine Eltern -
wenn ich ehrlich ganz bin -
nicht wollten.
Du warst frech, du warst lebhaft,
du hast alles getan,
was sie nicht wollten.
War das schon so früh?
- Ja! Du warst ein Rebell.
Das war Geev nicht.
- Ich weiss, ich weiss.
In meiner Erinnerung ...
- Geev war brav.
Ist er heute noch.
Ich verspreche dir jetzt,
dass ich nach der Reise zurückkomme.
Ja, wunderbar. Okay.
Pass auf dich auf!
- Ja, das mache ich. Danke schön.
Du musst Frauen immer fernbleiben.
- Das mache ich.
Da lacht er.
- Er lacht auch. Mit Recht.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Mit dem Auto zu reisen,
das ist es eben.
Alle steigen in den Flieger
und am anderen Ort aus.
Das ist wie ein Kulturschock.
Aber durch die Ländereien zu fahren,
sich langsam einzuleben,
das ist einfach schön.
Und das macht man viel zu wenig.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Ich glaube, hier müssen wir ...
Das ist jetzt Kroatien, oder?
Ja, nein.
Wir waren jetzt in Kroatien.
Ist das Serbien?
- Wir waren jetzt in Slowenien.
Das ist Kroatien.
Die Frage ist: Was machen wir hier?
Müssen wir hier schauen oder nicht?
Nein, wenn es nicht Serbien ist ...
Sonst fragen wir einfach.
Hola!
* Sie sprechen Englisch. *
Hey, wo sind wir? Thank you!
- Thank you. Bye-bye.
Warte kurz! - Jetzt kommt
doch nicht Griechenland.
Warte kurz! Halt an, Amigo!
Wo sind wir hier?
Was quatscht der?
Wir sind doch nicht in Albanien.
Ich schaue mal auf der Karte.
Schauen wir mal auf Google Maps!
Wo sind wir?
Ah, jetzt gehen wir nach Kroatien?
* Fröhliche Gitarrenmusik *
Was heisst das, "Custom Office"?
Ah, ist das ein Zoll?
Customs, alles Polizei.
Was ist denn das?
Ah, ist das ein Zoll?
* Salar lacht. *
Schon wieder?
Ich frage mal, wo wir hier sind.
Hello!
- Hello.
Do you speak english or german? No?
Is Serbia?
- Is Serbia?
Croatia. Okay.
Hello.
- Hello.
* Balkanische Blasmusik *
Wir sind beide
in extrem guter Stimmung.
Und, äh ... Es ist ein Roadtrip.
Wir schauen einfach mal,
was passt und was sich ergibt.
* Eindringliche Streichmusik:
"Versailles" von SaraoMusic *
Du, Salar,
was sind deine ersten Erinnerungen
ans Persische
und ans Schweizerische?
Meine Kindheitserinnerungen sind sehr
persisch und doch sehr schweizerisch.
Ich würde sagen, vielleicht eher
persisch geprägt als schweizerisch.
Das ist lustig.
Obwohl wir in der Schweiz waren.
Weil zu Hause alles persisch war?
Ja, und weil meine Eltern
lange dachten,
sie würden nach dem Krieg
zurückkehren.
Es war ja nie so,
dass wir nicht in den Iran wollten.
Es hat sich einfach alles so ergeben.
Aber wir lebten sehr persisch.
Lustigerweise lebt meine Mutter
heute immer noch sehr persisch,
obwohl sie
als Schweizerin geboren wurde
und 20 Jahre
in der Schweiz gelebt hat,
bevor sie in den Iran ging.
Das ist schon sehr interessant.
Sie lebt uns das auch sehr stark vor.
* Verspielte Zupfklänge *
* Intensive Streichmusik *
Jetzt ist gut, glaube ich.
Jetzt ist Zeit.
Bis morgen früh!
- Ja.
Ah!
* Geheimnisvolle Blasmusik *
* Energiegeladene Musik *
(Das Erwachsenwerden zwischen
zwei Kulturen war schwierig -
für mich und meine Familie.)
Meine Eltern haben einen mitgemacht,
mich immer mal wieder
auf dem Polizeiposten abgeholt.
Dazu muss ich allerdings sagen:
Bagatellen.
Wir haben keine Dinge verbrochen,
die schlimm wären.
Aber Disziplinarkommission, ich habe
in der Schule viel Ärger gemacht,
man hat mich
aus einer Klasse geworfen.
Es gab einen Lehrer, der sagte,
er könne nicht unterrichten,
wenn ich im Schulzimmer sitze.
Mein Vater wollte immer, dass wir
möglichst schweizerisch aufwachsen
und möglichst unauffällig sind,
wie alle anderen.
Ihm war extrem peinlich,
dass ich so ausscherte.
Ich glaube, ich war während
dieser Zeit ein unmöglicher Typ.
Hast du damals angefangen,
dich gegen das Persische zu stellen?
Wann hat das angefangen?
Ich habe mich nicht dagegengestellt.
Es ging mir einfach auf die Nerven.
Die Leute kamen und waren drei Monate
bei uns zu Hause, und das Geköch.
Und meine Mutter war gestresst.
Das gab viel Unruhe und war
in der Schweiz einfach schwierig.
Das ging mir auf die Nerven.
Und auch das persische "Taarof".
D.h., ich gehe in einen Laden,
kaufe eine Banane, möchte sie zahlen.
Der Verkäufer sagt:
"Gh'aabel nadaareh",
"Das hat keinen Wert,
ich schenke es Ihnen."
Dann muss man viermal sagen:
"Doch, ich möchte es zahlen",
und der andere sagt wieder:
"Nein, es hat keinen Wert."
Verdammt, du kannst ja nicht
rauslaufen und nicht zahlen.
Was ist das für ein Theater?
Solche Dinge wurden mir immer ferner.
Ich bin so geradeaus, ich sage den
Leuten ins Gesicht, wenn etwas ist.
Das erwarte ich auch. Ich mag,
wenn ich weiss, woran ich bin.
Aber darauf möchte ich mich
jetzt wieder einlassen.
* Rasante Handorgelmusik *
Istanbul? Istanbul.
So, also.
Hier sehen wir jetzt ungefähr ...
Wir sind jetzt unterwegs nach
Swilengrad, wir sind ungefähr hier.
Es sind noch ein paar Kilometer,
dann sind wir auf dem langen Weg
von hier bis nach Istanbul.
Wir werden diese Umfahrung machen.
Wir versuchen heute -
es ist schon noch wahnsinnig weit ...
Hei, ei, ei! Bis da, hier entlang.
Bis nach Ankara,
der Hauptstadt der Türkei.
* Orientalische Musik *
* Sphärische Klänge *
So, jetzt fahren wir also
von Europa nach Asien,
über den Bosporus.
Das ist eine Art Symbol dieser Reise,
ein Symbol zweier Kulturen
und einer Welt,
der Brücke zwischen zwei Kulturen.
Hey, wir haben es geschafft.
- Wir haben es geschafft.
Fix und fertig.
Also: 2'948 km, wir sind in Ankara.
Es ist genau 0 Uhr.
Wir sind - ich weiss nicht,
wie viele Stunden - unterwegs.
Aber es ist gut.
* Orientalische Klänge *
* Stimmengewirr *
Ankara ist für mich
ein wichtiger Punkt auf dieser Reise,
weil sich meine Eltern
im November 1980 entschieden haben,
wegen des Kriegs
den Iran zu verlassen,
ihre ganze Existenz aufzugeben.
Sie kamen in 48 Std. mit einem Bus -
es muss eine Höllenfahrt
gewesen sein -
zusammen mit anderen nach Ankara.
Das war von der Swissair organisiert.
Von hier
ging das Flugzeug in die Schweiz.
Meine Eltern
erzählten mir das immer wieder.
Es muss eine Horrorfahrt gewesen sein
im Bus.
Die Fahrer machten fliegende Wechsel,
man konnte nicht anhalten, aufs WC.
Man musste einfach flüchten.
Diese Reise haben wir jetzt vor uns.
Es war wichtig, eine Nacht hier zu
sein. Dann gehen wir eigentlich ...
Klar, in die andere Richtung,
reise ich jetzt wieder in den Iran.
Auch das ist irgendwie symbolisch.
* Intensive Klaviermusik *
Meine Eltern wollten eigentlich
im Iran bleiben, das weiss ich.
Es war wegen uns Kindern
und der Schweizer Mutter,
dass wir nicht im Krieg
bleiben mussten. Wir gingen.
Aber sie liebten den Iran,
sie lieben ihn heute noch.
Ja ...
Es muss wahnsinnig schwer
gewesen sein.
Mein Vater vermisste den Iran sehr,
meine Mutter auch.
Ich weiss auch nicht, da kann man
sich wohl nicht genug bedanken.
Es gibt keine Worte dafür.
* Melancholische Klänge *
* Sanfte Streichmusik *
(Wir verlassen Ankara
und fahren nach Erzurum -
die letzte Etappe vor dem Iran.)
(Und immer wieder auf unserer Reise:
Begegnungen mit Menschen,
Einladungen zum Tee ...)
Chocolate, Swiss.
- Yes.
Haben wir das Auto abgeschlossen?
Ja, oder?
Erzurum? Erzurum?
Erzurum, oh, oh!
* Er spricht Türkisch. *
600 km, oh, oh!
Oh, schau, hier! Ah!
- Oh!
Reto, Salar.
- Du?
Abdullah.
- Abdullah. Aha.
In the ... Schwierig, ohne ...
Es ist so schwierig.
Er wärmt sogar die Tassen vor,
er ist ein unglaublicher Typ.
Es spielt auch keine Rolle,
dass man nichts versteht.
Man sitzt zusammen da, es ist schön.
Yes.
* Salar lacht. *
Football yes.
Galatasaray no?
* Sie sprechen Türkisch. *
All the best.
- Yes.
Ciao.
* Emotionale Musik *
Bye-bye.
Ein friedlicher Typ!
Bruder, du kannst hier sitzen
und Tee trinken.
Vielen herzlichen Dank, danke.
Okay, ciao. Alles Gute.
Alles Gute.
- Danke, danke.
(Die persische Kultur - sie ist
aus meinem Leben fast verschwunden.)
Der Bruch war,
als mein Vater gestorben ist.
Das hat uns geschüttelt als Familie.
Es hat sich ... alles verändert.
Ich habe mich distanziert, vielleicht
aus Schutz, ich weiss es nicht.
Wir haben es nicht mehr so gelebt.
Bis damals haben wir zu Hause
Persisch gesprochen.
Es ist schon sehr ...
- Danach nicht mehr?
Das war dann eigentlich vorbei.
Nur noch selten, wenn es jemand
nicht verstehen sollte.
* Orientalisch Musik *
Jetzt gehen wir zum Bäcker.
Deutsch?
- Farsi. Deutsch?
Sprichst du Deutsch?
- Sprechen Sie auch Deutsch?
Ja. - Haben Sie mal
in Deutschland gelebt?
Wann sind Sie zurückgekommen?
Erst ein Jahr? Warum?
Kein Leben, kein Leben.
Also, Sefer,
es war mir eine grosse Freude.
Danke.
- Alles Gute.
Alles Gute.
Einen schönen Tag.
* Klagende Streichmusik *
So.
Diese Hunde tun mir so leid.
Ich glaube, der Übergang in den Iran
wird mir schon einfahren.
Ich spüre es.
Wir kommen immer näher.
Es ist mit guten Gefühlen verbunden,
ich freue mich.
Ich habe eigentlich
zu lange gewartet, denke ich jetzt.
* Orientalisches Flötenspiel *
* Langanhaltender Ruf
eines Muezzins *
* Klopfen, Öffnen einer Tür *
Du, es ist mega kalt.
- Wirklich?
Ich habe alles angezogen
und mir ist immer noch kalt.
Weisst du, wie kalt es ist?
- -24 °C.
-24 °C, aber trocken,
ähnlich wie im Engadin.
Gut. Bis nachher.
- Bis nachher.
* Orientalische Musik *
(In etwa 3 Std.
erreichen wir die Grenze zum Iran -
wir werden nervös.)
Die Karre ist noch da.
Schau mal, vielleicht wäre gut, wenn
du das hast, wenn mit mir was wäre.
Ja. - Wenn sie das finden,
gibt es Probleme.
Das sind meine anderen Papiere
für am Zoll.
Warum geht es nicht?
Das Scheissgerät, wirklich!
Links abbiegen verboten.
- Geil.
Also, das Fahren
ist recht persisch bei mir.
Merkst du es?
- Ich merke es, sehr persisch.
Very persisch.
* Hupen *
* Intensive Streichmusik *
Es fährt mir jetzt schon ein, wenn
ich da durchfahre und mir vorstelle,
wie das für meine Eltern
gewesen sein muss.
Damals hast du ja
noch nicht viel mitbekommen.
Nein, ich war eineinhalb,
zum Glück nicht.
Was ich allerdings merke:
Ich bin extrem schreckhaft -
was eigentlich nicht so
zu meinem Naturell passt.
Aber ich bin wirklich sehr
schreckhaft. Und ich bin überzeugt:
Das kommt von den Bomben,
die in Teheran eingeschlagen sind.
Ich war ein Baby, meine Mama sagte,
ich hätte gezuckt und geheult.
Das sitzt einem wortwörtlich
in Mark und Bein.
Das ist vielleicht auch der Grund,
warum ich gegen jegliches Militär bin
und finde, dass wir heute nicht mehr
mit Waffen kämpfen sollten.
* Orientalische Klänge *
Hi!
- Hello.
* Unverständlicher Ausruf *
Yes! - Yes!
Hey, schau, der Lastwagen da!
Es wird immer rauer,
immer wilder, karger.
The way to Iran.
Es kommt mir vor wie
die letzte Möglichkeit zu tanken.
Wir müssen noch mal vor dem Zoll.
Wenn wir die ganze Nacht dort stehen
bei -24 °C, muss der Motor laufen.
Mach mir nicht Angst!
Du, die ganze Nacht
den Motor laufen lassen,
das hören jetzt viele in der Schweiz
nicht gerne. - Nein.
Hier hat man aber andere Probleme.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Eigentlich wollten wir
noch ein bisschen filmen,
aber in ein paar Kurven
sind wir an der Grenze.
Man sieht es hier. Und ...
Es hatte jetzt so viel Polizei,
Militär und Sperren,
dass es wohl schlau wäre,
das Zeug abzumontieren.
Es liegt jetzt einfach
nicht mehr drin, hier zu filmen.
So, jetzt gehen wir.
- Ja, das ist gut.
(Zwei Jahre haben wir uns
auf diese Reise vorbereitet,
haben versucht, an alles zu denken,
haben Papiere unterschrieben,
Anträge gestellt, Gebühren bezahlt,
und wissen doch nicht,
ob man uns in den Iran lässt.)
(Dafür haben wir zum ersten Mal
auf unserer Reise Angst.)
(Evtl. wären wir umgekehrt, hätten
wir gewusst, was uns erwartet.)
Nichts läuft. Uns fehlt ein Papier,
um das Auto in den Iran zu nehmen.
Das hat uns in der Schweiz
niemand gesagt.
Es zu importieren,
würde jegliche Kosten sprengen.
Das wäre ein Mehrfaches
des Werts dieses Autos.
Achtung!
Hör auf!
Ich weiss nichts mehr, muss mich sam-
meln. Wir brauchen einen neuen Plan.
Wir müssen das Auto hierlassen,
uns von ihm verabschieden.
Und mit Fahrer und Taxi
oder einem gemieteten,
und wenn wir keines mieten können,
mit einem Fahrer weiterkommen.
Wir können unsere Reise
nicht aufgeben.
Aber jetzt
ist auf einmal alles anders.
Ich dachte nicht, dass das die
letzten Meter in diesem Auto sind.
Ehrlich gesagt,
weiss ich jetzt gar nichts mehr.
Aber es gibt jetzt Kosten
und Zeitverlust.
Wir sind schon
vier Tage zu spät gestartet
und müssen zwei Tage früher aus dem
Land wegen Retos Journalistenvisum.
Es ist jetzt alles tough.
(Wir haben es geschafft.)
(Wir können in den Iran einreisen,
müssen aber unser Auto abgeben.)
(Und zwar für immer.)
Wir sind im Iran.
Die Freude
ist jetzt ein bisschen gedämpft,
dadurch,
dass wir das Auto hierlassen müssen.
Aber: selber blöd, selbst schuld.
Wir geben nicht auf,
finden einen neuen Weg.
Das auch?
- Ja, ich brauche alles.
Vier Leute
reden auf Persisch auf mich ein.
Wir haben so viel Ware und wussten
nicht, dass wir ausladen müssen.
Sie stressen uns,
setzen uns leicht unter Druck.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Kann ich den Scheiss
nicht hier lassen?
Ich habe keine Nerven mehr
für die Scheiss-Kaffeetasse.
Du wirst noch froh sein.
- Nein, ich brauche keinen Kaffee.
Ehrlich, ich kann es nicht
rumschleppen. - Ich nehme es mit.
Du spinnst doch.
Schau mal, das hat hier drin Platz.
Bist du fit?
- Nein, ich bin voll am Ende.
Jetzt heisst es "Ciao, Subaru",
den holen wir sicher nicht mehr.
Der bleibt genau hier. Wir können
nicht noch mal 6'000 km fahren.
* Hupen *
Wir sind im Iran, Reto.
Ja, wir fahren jetzt so,
mit dieser Schnur fahren wir jetzt.
Jetzt kommt noch ein Dritter.
- Wir sind jetzt zu sechst.
(Im zweiten Teil heute in einer Woche
machen wir uns auf Spurensuche
im Iran -
zusammen mit dem Cousin
meines Vaters, Vali-Khan Bahrampoori,
und seiner Frau Shuku-Kanun.)
(Ich entdecke das Haus,
in dem ich
meine früheste Kindheit verbrachte
und das wir unter Beschuss
verlassen mussten.)
(Dann merken wir, dass wir
auf unserer Reise überwacht werden.)
Was will jetzt der wieder von uns?
Mein Gott! Einfach nach Hause.
Wenn ich könnte, würde ich heute
in den Flieger steigen und gehen.